good morning Hank it's Tuesday great
news Netflix cast re ensemble for
adaptation of John Green's let it snow
it's true sort of it's definitely a
starry ensemble Kiernan Shipka from
chilling Adventures of Sabrina shamak
more from spider-man into the
spider-verse
Mitchell hope of day a rush Anna Akana
Joan freaking Cusack I could not agree
more with vultures assessment that this
is a very charming cast for Netflix is
John Green adaptation let it snow and I
share the sense of anticipation
expressed in the headline Netflix is
bringing this John Green novel to life
and we can't wait there is a problem
though which is that this John Green
novel is not a John Green novel so back
in 2007 and 2008 my friends Lauren
Myracle and Maureen Johnson and I wrote
a book together called let it snow we
each wrote one romance story set at
nearly the same time in the same town in
North Carolina during a blizzard and
then we work together to interconnect
the stories in little ways so that each
story would be kind of a window into the
others we had so much fun writing this
book and I really hope that you can feel
the joy when you read it but the point
is it is exactly as much Lauren and
Maureen's book as it is mine quick side
note to emphasize how excited I am about
the casting and how amazing this whole
thing is like when Lauren and Maureen
and I wrote this book I had this like
secret hope that it would one day be
turned into a movie but that hope was so
unrealistic and ludicrous that I was
embarrassed about it and now we're here
and the director Luke Snellen is a
wonderful guy and the script is
incredible like it made me cry with
laughter but also you know how sometimes
you cry because something is just so
sweet and lovely and oh yes that but
right I get why this is happening in the
press about the movie Lauren and Maureen
are both successful and acclaimed
authors but my name probably gets more
clicks and I get that it is hard to
write a headline that contains the names
of three separate authors and also
several actors but I think this kind of
thing can become a self-fulfilling
prophecy like my name is in those
headlines because I am better known but
I am better known in part because my
name is in those headlines I feel like
maybe the better way to handle this
would be for instance Netflix is why a
Christmas movie let it snow has a
chillingly good cast led by Kiernan
Shipka which also gets points for the
chilling puns but in the end of that
headline might get fewer clicks because
it isn't packed with names optimized for
search engines now I realize this is not
the world's biggest deal and might in
fact be the world's smallest deal but
it's a
personal experience of a broader
phenomenon that concerns me which is
that clickability is more important than
accuracy those of us who make stuff
online want algorithms to pick our stuff
and so we are incentivized to tell you
whatever truth will hold and capture
your attention because that's what the
algorithms want to do this isn't quite
the same thing as being untrustworthy or
spreading misinformation like John
Green's let it snow really is coming to
Netflix with an amazing cast it's just
that Lauren Myracle and Maureen
Johnson's let it snow are too and so you
end up seeing at least in the headlines
stories that are true while also being
distorted you end up seeing a truth that
will grab your attention which is never
quite the truth of course this isn't new
like when I was a kid the 11 o'clock
news would always start with something
like is this factory poisoning children
more after the break and it doesn't mean
the websites I read are the local news i
watch are inherently evil or anything I
just think understanding what media
wants from you helps you to understand
what they're providing to you I know it
often feels like as readers and viewers
we have no control over the huge forces
that are shaping information flow but I
actually think if we pay careful
attention to the information we ingest
we do end up changing the way
information works at least for ourselves
so yeah I can't wait for warned miracle
and Maureen Johnson and John Green's let
it snow to be a movie Hank I will see
you on Friday